hello today we're
talking with Kerry Synanon Kerry did her
got her PhD in literature from Trinity
Dublin her dissertation was on the
writings of slave masters and slaves and
it is the subject of a book that's under
consideration by North Carolina
University Press tentatively called
slave masters in the language of self
traders planters and colonial agents
1750 to 1834 she's currently visiting
here at Yale at the British Art Center
as part of their visiting Scholars
Program and then will be returning to
Galway where she is a research fellow at
the Moore Institute at the National
University of Ireland Kerry it's great
to have you here so let's begin by you
someone has a background in literature
and you're doing you're at the British
Arts Centre are doing some really
interesting interdisciplinary work on on
slavery in the relationship between not
only masters and slaves but also
representations of that could you say a
little about the the work that you've
been doing and that's brought you here
to Yale
yes well the book on slave masters is
almost finished and in researching for
it a lot of material came up about slave
woman and slave women as mothers and so
that give rise to this new project which
I received the funding for from the
visiting scholarship program and I'm
really looking in a multidisciplinary
way at representations of slave women as
mothers it's a very hidden history the
Royal archives are not very yielding
these were hidden histories that weren't
necessarily recorded and so
multidisciplinary approach looking at
literature looking at the historical
archive but also looking at the visual
arts can really offer us some insights
into understanding more deeply the kind
of forces within which slave women were
constructed represented and even
consumed by slavery and are you focusing
on on the British Caribbean so Jamaica
you and I assumed you were here before
with with a by Nucky fellow and
and when is this related to the work
that you're doing there as well indeed I
was looking at the archive of Thomas
distal word of a famous archive offered
Jamaican overseer who kept almost ten
thousand pages worth of Diaries over
decades and within that archive
thistlewood tells us very empirical
details about the slave plantation and
he doesn't tell us much about the lives
of slaves but throughout you can see
traces of what the women's lives must
have been like in particular he's quite
infamous and Douglas Hall and Trevor
Bernhard the this historians have talked
about his almost daily routine sexual
exploitation of women and so when I was
looking at that archive I also popped
over to the Yale Center for British art
and started to look at the images and
that represented the slave woman's body
as both a sexualized object but also as
a site of the reproduction of form of
more slaves
so the meanings the demands this the the
significance is of the slave women's
bodies are caught between a myriad of
forces within the slave plantation
system and I really wanted to come back
and have a look at more detail well that
I mean this is a fascinating subject
because you say there are all these
different ways of looking at these
enslaved women that somehow have to be
reconciled but I I think in some ways
those kind of ways of thinking about
women in general or you know with us
today so could we begin maybe by by
looking at one of the one of the first
images in in the collection that you
yeah there's a story to tell I think if
we begin with this rather infamous and
well-known image of the seeable Venus
from Angola to the West Indies it's a
really an ironic imitation of
Botticelli's Venus right exactly and
that strikes us immediately and of
course these kinds of planter histories
and that these kinds of writings travel
writings rich
by and for the plant okra see were very
powerful pieces of writing and
perpetuating ideologies that continue to
support slavery and here we have really
as a sort of slave masters fantasy and
what strikes us immediately is is as the
color is Reyes this is not Botticelli's
Venus this is a black woman who is being
harnessed but we can if we look closely
that the harnessing is is also her slave
chance and she's wearing a slave collar
and so she's not steering her she'll
chariot at all she's being forcibly
drilling yeah and the contrast between
her and the white cherubs around her is
really quite heartbreaking in so many
ways but she's also sexualized here
she's not allied the sort of the hair or
the hands that would cover her modesty
in the way that the Venus de Medici
statue is a lie and she's really been
forcibly denuded by the gaze of the
viewer and she's being harnessed for her
sexual right favors she's being
harnessed for her labor as a slave she's
being harnessed for her reproductivity
as well and so all these competing
forces I think can be seen in this image
now was the artist so this who's the
artist
here is the engraver Thomas start he
would have been he drew this to me this
engraving for the the history of Brian
Edward who was a very powerful planter
right yeah and it so I guess I mean the
questions I have is that is it who's the
intended audience and what is the
intention of I mean what is this image
meant to elicit if there are there ways
that you can pull or that you can kind
of venture to kind of discuss that well
this is what so this is why I think a
multidisciplinary approach is so
necessary because that's exactly I'm not
sure we could ever fully recover what
the intended audience would have seen
because it's so hard for us to
dissociate lard or
however I think it's very clear that it
is a an ironic fantasy but that's also
got realism in there she is a valuable
unit right she is a sexualized object so
she's definitely being exhibitors I
think in this way but she's also being
exhibited as as I say as I'm really
quite productive aha
I mean she's surrounded by as you said
this but like kind of images of the
Greek I said you know Greek gods and
this new classical thing and that's I
wonder is this meant then to be humorous
that the kind of irony of say of calling
you know an enslaved person caesar
pompey or something in that way as as
some kind of terrible joke or I mean I I
mean to us it's it's disconcerting to me
at least it seems very disconcerting to
see this contrast because I can't help
but think about a whole range of the way
that they that Europe and the America
and the Africa has been you know
depicted in the bodies of women as well
and so it's kind of disconcerting now is
there a way that you can take the the
work of Brian Edwards himself and and
and and match up in some way with with
the representation of the women in the
enemies yeah I mean this is the thing I
mean she's being Tim behringer writes
about this image in his and a book on
art and emancipation in Jamaica and he
says she's being served up I think it's
a really good way of putting it and yes
you're right there is a horrible irony
there's a joke being played here which
is deeply deeply disturbing but would
not have been disturbing to the audience
the plant okra sea audience
don't forget so many of the West Indian
planters were not resident there right
and they're being they're wanting to be
told by their colleague Brian Edwards
that all as well at the that the their
plantations are indeed thriving and
prosperous
and really this history as it was and is
really an account of of the the
dependency neither needs the economic
argument for maintaining slavery in the
colonies of you know this is definitely
an absolute right they're not the
British Empire half - extracting
everything they can from their colonies
and this woman she's a metonymy in way
she represents right right all slave
women she she will be the tool they used
to get so many things to to harness so
many desires that are at play within the
slavery system right and even to the
point of in some ways representing the
middle passage itself absolutely in this
image it's a deeply disturbing re
articulation of that yeah yeah
absolutely people may know that one of
the earliest accounts we have of the
slave woman as a mother is in Richard
lagoons history of barbarous from 16:57
aha and he talks about this is again a
true and exact history of the island of
Barbados which is telling his English
audience but really everything that's
going on in Barbados and how the
planters run their plantations and all
kind of the people's there and he is an
apologist for slavery but within that
story he has a small extract about am a
Native American woman who has helped him
right he's had worms in his feet and her
name is Jericho and he says that she was
brought here by an English leave captain
who she rescued hung he then sold her
into slavery so that's from 1657 that
story that idea of the slave woman has
both the object of desire and as the
producer of more slaves is really in
these kind of histories from the very
very beginning and then if we turn to
the historical record and this came up
when I was looking at the slave masters
record so I came across some interesting
extracts from John Newton a famous
English slave couch and who then became
a very famous abolitionist
author of the amazing grant indeed and
he's more well-known not in his journal
of a slave dealer he has several
extracts about rejecting slave woman for
what he calls being fall and breasted
and I didn't know what to do with these
extracts because he takes on older women
right he takes on pregnant women
he takes women with small children he
rejects slaves who he says are curly
made and sometimes he says they have a
bad moist and he sent them back so I'm
not sure you know it's hard to know
exactly what that meant but this
repetition of women having long breasts
and therefore not being purchasable in
his opinion as a repeated thing
throughout his journals and so one can
speculate with this kind of historical
record as to what criteria are in
operation even at the moment of
purchasing slave women if we think of
how I sort of desirable the civil be
Venus's me to look and it's arguable
that that that women who did not conform
to certain ideals of beauty were
rejected by slave traders at the very
coast but so this is so is he looking at
this long breasted mrs. Ben but a sign
of someone who's whose who's who's older
and has been been a nurse for many years
or is it or is it more or is it simply
just visually unappealing and and not
kind of his like conception of what an
enslaved woman should look like it's
it's really really hard to know I can he
takes on several old woman and he says
calls him alderman and his Diaries his
journals on the slave coast really talk
about how hard it is to get hold of
slaves you know it's not easy to fill up
that ship with several hundred slaves
and within that competitive environment
he still repeatedly rejects women and
they are often women with babies but um
they won't have there won't be that old
right he'll reject women with long
breasts and that you know this is why I
multi-disciplinary as approach is needed
because I can only take that evidence
and put it alongside other pieces of
evidence and try and build up a picture
of this history
of what forces were at work and I'm
arguing I think that yes ideals of
beauty of when when these women were
going to emerge on the other side of the
Mid Atlantic passage and be viewed as
they were by their perspective buyers
what criteria were in operation well and
also are is he looking for at these
women as being a concubine
you know that this is what's so very
very disturbing you know whether that
that the you know it must have been part
of what was understood to be as I say
their their multifarious functions the
slave women because as I understand it
the the slave trade to Barbados and
Jamaica is predominantly men they're
looking for for for men who will be
laboring in the sugar cane fields and
and I don't know that they're that
they're I are you do you have kind of
statistical I don't know how many I
don't have statistics on the proportion
but you're absolutely right that the
highest prices go for grower man but
they will fill their ships but right
down to children sure and and aldermen
because as the Polly's I mean onions
writing in the 1750s by which point the
plantations are fully up and running
right and unlike at the beginning in
Barbados where you need the hard labor
to get the you know in the 1650s to get
the islands reductive know you've got
the colonists there you've got what
would have been called the Creoles who
are resident there and they have their
rather lavish domestic high tolls to run
and so the the many rules for many more
different kinds of slaves proliferate
uh-huh and so that there will be an
understanding that you need more than
just men to take the fields right and I
assume they're also saying that that as
there is pushback against the
transatlantic slave trade the need to be
able to reproduce
señores rather than replace your
you're working population is is changing
as well well and that's really true and
I mean Michael Creighton is one of the
slave historians who has done a lot of
work on the rates of infanticide for
example on the plantations women off of
South performed abortions by slave women
who would rather do that unspeakable act
the law their children to be born into
slavery and so he calls their conditions
similar to those of the Nazi
concentration camps and yes reproduction
rates were very very low so that was a
source of anxiety right right what
really struck me here at the Y CBO and
looking at the images to accompany a lot
of these and pro-slavery accounts of the
West Indies what struck me was the
product the predominance of this image
of the slave mother and her children as
something else entirely as almost a
romanticized sign of a rural little yeah
yeah and yeah and I yeah this looks like
out of a kind of pastoral tradition that
you could easily kind of imagine this as
in in the England English countryside
and Italy except that it isn't so say
say a little more about what's happening
yeah so so really what I wanted to come
back to the ycb a to do was to hunt
first time it was there and I think this
if we look at this image this is very
typical of many of the images that
accompany these kind of picturesque
accounts of the of the islands and this
one is a picturesque church the island
of Jamaica and of course hickville was
trans an architect but he was
undertaking landscape drawings he came
over to Jamaica from 1820 to 1820 one
and did a series of plates to accompany
this chair and that has you absolutely
right in saying it his readers will will
be familiar with this as reminiscent of
the English picturesque the wrong
tradition
and it seems as if the mother here and
her two children are almost an
underlining that all is well all is
peaceful all is calm right
slavery is almost erased except as you
say it can never be because this is a
slave colony yes a mother with her
children but it looks very much like the
God sort of travel paintings I say this
could be we're not for the individuals
in Italy or someplace like that estate
and to the in in some ways to the viewer
appealing to the kind of interest in
this exotic idyllic place without any
kind of weighing human suffering yeah
and it's touched tapping into that
romantic tradition that the there is
ease within a laboring class we can we
can see it repeated this image repeated
in his bridge over the White River and
now if we look closely at the figures at
the bottom left this is a washerwoman
uh-huh that would have been a very hard
job and often washer women are depicted
with their children um as if this is
something one can do at ease
mm-hmm again the very little is
undisturbed goes right back as you say
to the pastoral tradition and we can put
it actually in the tradition of maybe
this image called the harvest
yes okay by by James herring right um so
if we look here this is the kind of
imagery that equalist is drawing on here
we have uh an estate in England James
herring is actually the painter and the
owner of this estate and he has depicted
himself in the back row and they're
riding through his horse on his horse
through the cornfield or wheat field and
he has sending a message to himself and
to everybody around him that I run a
good a good estate my workers have time
to if we look at the close-up right and
my my labouring women have
to nurse their infants right at their
ease and there's a perfect balance
between labor and production and
humanity right on my estate and that
seems to be the kind of tradition he's a
good man
yes he's a good master providing for his
and their and they're happy and content
and this is kind of a timeless
celebration and all the kind of things
that go in and the nursing mother is
sort of the underlining of that because
this is the most tender relationship you
can have and if this relationship can
exist here then we know all as well
yes because there's it there's
continuity that's kind of built into the
continuity of going back to Madonna all
right yeah so the images that we've
looked at so far depict a landscape that
is kind of pleasurable it's a place
where people are at their leisure and
that sort of thing but it's not the kind
of landscape image that springs to mind
when I think about the real work of a
plantation in Jamaica and could you say
more about you know that and is this an
imaginary spot or is this a Jamaican
scene these are these are real spots but
of course it's in the depiction of them
that that that's that's we encounter so
many interesting questions just like
this these are these are real spots but
they are very much being painted in a
tradition of the picturesque landscape
and they we can have other examples
William Beckford was another very
powerful to make an planter and he
commissioned this series of prints by
George Robertson and they were the
paintings and they were turned into
prints and here we have a view in the
island of Jamaica it's much more exotic
and a bit more wild but again it's
drawing on the Gainsborough tradition
right yes you can
I there's the the central figures and
and there's the livestock and it's kind
of in this as if they're not truly there
as if nobody engineered this landscapes
peaceable kingdom that they're all
pointed right and with and with the
woman again and say women
Center yes of the lower center of the
yes as if what one appears to be
possibly a mulatto woman aha and again
the mulatto woman was almost another
interesting figure that will come to
talk about a bit more but she seems to
be at her leisure to buy goods from
another slave whose Huck stirring and
this is really a sign again you'll see
this repeated image of of slaves being
able to almost be richer than the
peasants back in England that's another
message these these images want to send
that this is a productive look high
productive and exotic of this land is
look how easily it lends itself to
yielding produce and look at how easy it
is for people to extract that produce
you're not going to see the kind of
plantations that we might see in
something like twelve years of sleeve
right right yeah there's no there's no
violence you know in any of these okay
we we go now to Augustine Oh Bernie ass
could you say something about about this
work well he's one of the most
fascinating artists very very prolific
he was born an Italian but he soon came
to England and with Robert Adam who was
on a grand tour and he was given many
commissions in England to paint em
stately homes and then he hooked up with
Sir William Young who was the governor
of Dominica and in 1770 he traveled with
Sir William young to Dominica and it was
almost as if he was commissioned to
paint and marketing right these were
going to be exhibited back home come
here look at this wonderful lovely
Island and certainly the sexuality of
the slave woman as a part of that now
there are many different ways of looking
at this kind of image which is called a
linen market with a linen stall and a
vegetable seller in the West Indies and
commentators who talk about bringing
asses work really talk about the the
commodity culture he's depicting here
absolutely yeah and as you say I'm
it's nobody's suffering here right we
have a group of Carib Indians on the
Left coming to market with their produce
we have what Bruni ass is constructing
us they're sort of very calmly and
desirable mulatto woman uh-huh
she's possibly free at this point she's
buying linen from the slave women and so
we have a little economy or a sitting
here and he's definitely drawn an an
ethnographic tradition absolutely that
we might feel very uneasy with today but
what really struck me about this image
um if we go to a close up off the bottom
right hand corner she's not very visible
initially but what struck me was this
image of our slave mother with her baby
nursing and so the slave mother is there
right right
within this scene and she's nursing very
comfortably and happily and this is
definitely an RD and ideal right and
again if this is marketing in a form
this is a part of it too is that this
you know is a healthy baby yes and just
kind of depicts the overall abundance of
this island and in fact if you look at
the the entire painting it's not too
different it seems to me from the way
that the Caribbean is continues to be
marketed as this kind of exotic place
that's familiar yet is not exactly and I
mean that this is the thing people would
have known these people would have been
very familiar at this point with the
works of painters like Canaletto and the
Heike Italian it and so these these
these colors as you say it's registering
the exotica but also it's not too
unfamiliar it's it's it's familiar and a
little bit different at the same time so
there's this enticement and and
femininity is playing a huge part in
this image and this is one of many yeah
absolutely yeah the few men that are in
this this painting are kind of periphery
they're not there they're not the focus
the light is not shining on
if we want to get to the more disturbing
aspect of it of course it is a male of
year who is being intended as well and
that and so and of course within this
market every woman there is a kind of
commodity whether she's a slave or or a
free mulatto and was even more
disturbing than if we returned to the
touching image of the slave mother
nursing her baby is that that they are
both commodities to and within the slave
system that that connection is not going
to continue right that slave is not
right does not belong to its mother that
baby belongs to its master and as a
chattel to be traded and sold at will
and so that's the disturbing truth the
slave mother in this image I would
suggest really disturbs any sense that
all as well which I guess makes me
wonder and this sigh I know you you'll
get to is what is what is both I mean
there seems to be work going on in in
these paintings to to present the slave
system in the most desirable light but
it the images themselves undercut I
thought that that as well could you say
more about that is that yeah well this
is this I think you've really you really
put your finger on it and you know you
can't present an image of her mother
slave feeding her child as if it is the
Madonna and Child right without
immediately realizing that of course it
isn't
and and that's I don't think that's just
our lens from our contemporary
perspective the viewer of this painting
back in England or in Dominica would
know that these are people whose lives
are to be bought and sold and so there
is this uneasy unresolvable tension
within the paintings by Bruni ass and he
you know he's often read or somebody who
reproduces the racialized ideology of
the planter class but at the same
I mean these are individuals who
disturbed that they can't stay in their
static positions they are they are also
real human beings right right the the
terms of their of their existence can't
help but kind of come through yeah
in that actually though does I mean are
there are of course abolitionists minded
painters they're also depending the
Jamaican scene and West Indies can you
well are you working with those yeah
well that was what brought me to to this
was was the really rather famous blitz
by William Blake John Steadman's
narrative offers five years expedition
to Suriname and John John Steadman was
himself very conflicted he he wrote what
really is an abolitionist piece while
claiming himself to think that we still
need slavery the images that that Blake
produced the prints that Blake produced
based on Steadman's drawings are
powerful indictments on what slaves had
to put up with but especially once the
body of the slave woman had to injure
again critics are very uneasy with some
of these images would she live woman
being lacerated and whipped naked slave
men being battered are on on crosses and
slave body is shown ginger unspeakable
horrors and um this weather weather
Stedman wanted these images to talita to
write Emancipation or not he didn't have
a say that people read these images as
powerful abolitionist arguments and a
month an arguments from the abolition of
slavery altogether right and I would
imagine that people looking at some of
these other more pastoral images are
looking at that knowing the images of
Blake that they're kind of have set
another way of reading into the images
of say Jamaica well this is what's so
interesting I mean what's really
interesting and you know
more work needs to be done on this but
what's really interesting is the very
tight timeline I think of abolition but
it really isn't until 17 years here yeah
that everybody wakes up and starts to
say this and that's not to say there
haven't been voices right before that
but as with every sort of awareness that
we have today we might think of our own
awareness of environmental issues
there's a history to that concern yeah
similarly there's a history to when
people start to set up and say we can't
be putting people into ships I mean when
they're the one Thomas Clarkson released
that image of the Brooke ship with the
famous image of the people packed like
barrels right that was an enormous
conscious really conscious Ness right
sir right I'm so yes you're absolutely
right people and and people will have
been reading abolitionist poetry
abolitionist material but almost more
the listeners argue the more the
planters argue back and so you get the
two strands of the discourse huh well as
you say the even though there is this
history of course to thinking about
slavery the slave trade and abolition by
the late 18th century it is it has
become the kind of question of the day
and I think this is certainly in this
next image is is very very evident yeah
it's an enormous contrast with what
we've seen before
again similar ideas at work but for a
totally different purpose John Smith was
an engraver highly highly regarded one
of the best Mets art injured around and
George Moreland was a very good painter
he could have been brilliant but he was
crippled by almost chronic alcoholism
and John barreled talks about him in his
in his book as somebody who's maybe been
underrated but these two prints came out
in 1790 John Smith seems to have
suggested to Moreland that they take
this opportunity as anti-slavery
sentiment is on the rise and they
produced these really quite expensive
prints and this one here is called the
slave trade
and we can see that a slave family is
that it's hard honestly of mother with
her infant who seems to be reaching up
to to nurse she's almost automatically
breath treating him as two different
slave captains are separating her
husband or her partner and herself and
she's being dragged into one boat and
her husband partner right this is how
the image is presenting it the family is
being dragged into another boat and he's
about to be beaten right by his owner so
it's a deliberately affecting scene it's
again you'll notice some of the romantic
ideas of the sublime and the romantic
landscape but this is back to the coast
of Africa that that Moreland and Smith
are taking us the people in the boat
have their faces covered and that's
reminiscent of the pose of the expulsion
from Eden yes absolutely there's the
dark clouds exam horizon yeah the and as
well so that the darkness of in the
lower left-hand corner
I guess the ocean yes and if we look
this man on the on the bottom right-hand
corner maybe not as easy to see but he's
casting a very lascivious look exactly
of woman and so we can see signal then
in what is a sentimental picture but I
also think there's a lot of satire in
operation we can see already that this
slave woman who is mother wife slave
also sexual object we can already see
all the Mary many forces not to mention
those with that will consume her child
as well
right it's designed to affect people
very powerfully and it goes along with
this other image called African
hospitality which also features a mother
two mothers a white mother and a black
mother this imagines what happens to
these travelers who've been shipwrecked
again on an imaginary coast yes
and we see a very strong African mother
with her two healthy strong babies
supporting and helping an almost
infinite white mother so there's a
satire there too and this is a
representation of of Africans as
entirely human
intelligent full of sentiment
appropriate right to the time ready to
help others and in return their barter
to slaves right and our these are
companion pieces yes yes to their above
from 1790 yes and we can focus in on the
mothers all right this is the slave
mother really trying to nurse her child
who's just underwear really of what's
happening it's a very tragic tragic
scene I think it's quite a moment of
realism in the midst of this sentimental
picture and then if we contrast that
with the depiction of the slave mother
mother what the African mother here with
the English mother who isn't even really
able to look at her child who's looking
for attention she's too weak and so
there's there's a depiction here a
deliberate satire on the English family
as opposed to the African family so
that's the discourse working in the
other direction there are these proof
these paintings were they presented just
as these illustrations that you might
frame and hang in your house or is there
like a story behind them or some are
they part of a larger narrative
well the these are these were
deliberately produced by Smith and
Moreland and they were going to be sold
for guinea apiece so these were quite
high end objects and the idea there was
these were prints that were made that
we're going to be desirable objects for
prominent and genteel anti-slavery
activists in in the cities and so it
would have been a way you you would
position them somewhere in your
household as a way of announcing your
intentions yes your sentiment in the
night senior you know apparently they
didn't sell as well as as they'd wanted
and my feeling about that
they're just too harsh right there quite
they're quite striking wrong critiques
yeah even if you're in abolition Asst
the depiction of the English family as
being treacherous yeah I'm being saved
on the one hand but ready to buy and
sell and the other it's quite a lot to
take it's much easier to just not have
sugar in your tea right these images up
on your wall yeah I can I can certainly
understand it is interesting though that
it's in some ways the the crisis is set
here on the coast of Africa indeed
indeed you know the you know and it's
the slave trade itself that is kind of
under indictment unless so the
plantation system indeed and and this is
it that you know come the 1790 safe they
they put everything into trying to
abolish the slave trade so one step at a
time and what's also very fascinating
about these Smith Moreland prints is
that these scenes and scenes like them
are repeated in abolitionist poetry so
I'll just quickly realize the millions
from Hannah more a poem that she eagles
feel Smith and Hannah more co-authored
whitey man he came from far sailing or
the briny flood who with help of British
tar buys up human flesh and blood with
the baby at my breast other two were
sleeping by in my Hut i sat at rest with
no thought of danger nigh and so it's
again the slave mother in this sense can
function as a powerful abolitionist tool
because what can be more affecting than
the idea of taking away a feeding baby
from its mother right and this of course
is in u.s. abolitionist literature this
is the one image that is is kind of
presented to to get a northern wide
audience notifies with that by talking
about the family yeah
kind of under attack so how do you how
does with your work
what do you kind of is this are you
bound by this kind of moment of the
struggle over the the end of the slave
trade or do you do you kind of bring
things up to the 1830s and the eventual
abolition of how do you kind of how do
you periodized yeah I think I think
we've our time line in this conversation
has moved a little bit back and forth
because we've ended on the high point of
abolition what will become the high
point of abolition and won't succeed of
course until the 1803 right but the the
kind of works we were talking about
earlier that the planters perspectives
keep going and Matthew Lewis travels to
has to make implantations in 1817 in his
his journal of a Western gee proprietor
is published just after emancipation to
show him as a good master and so we have
this discourse um
carrying on as you say and and then into
the the sort of post abolitionist period
of you know what will we do with without
with our newly free yes members of the
Empire indeed indeed
so I yes I think it will it would be
normal it would be right to go up and
have a good look right up to that point
of emancipation maybe a little bit
beyond and I'm really being led by the
material to see what the story there is
to tell well I think this is all very
exciting and interesting work I'm so
glad that we had a chance to meet you
and and what seems like the final week
that you have done herod yeah I don't
know why we don't find out people sooner
but it's been a great pleasure talking
to you thank you the best of luck you
knew your new job and thank you and
fine research I'm thanking thank you to
the Gilder Lehrman center for your time
and thanks to the Y CBA and everybody
there I've received a lot of support
that's good friends of ours thanks
thanks so much care ok